- Hi everyone, Sal here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Homeroom livestream.
Today, we're going to be
doing an ask me anything
about anything.
So, if you have your questions,
start to put them in the message boards
underneath this video
on Facebook or YouTube.
And we have team members,
who are going to surface
the questions to me
and feel free to be very
creative with your questions.
I'm happy to, I'm hard
to offend or surprise.
But before we get into that,
I will make my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So, if you're in a position to donate,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate
and any amount $10 $20
it all makes a difference
and allows us to provide a
free world class education
for anyone anywhere, at
least be part of that.
The other announcement
is, you know, I wanna give
a special shout out to
several organizations
that have helped Khan Academy,
especially through the COVID crisis.
We were already running into
deficit before the crisis
and then our server costs
have gone up dramatically
because our traffic is
almost 3X of what we saw
during normal times, we've
been trying to accelerate
content areas and various
programs for teachers and parents.
And so, special thanks to
Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly and Novartis and many others.
Amgen Foundation, many other
foundations and organizations
that have supported Khan
Academy over the years,
but especially during the
COVID crisis, to make sure
that we can support all of
y'all as much as possible.
Also, making an announcement,
if you've enjoyed
these live streams, you can
also access them as a podcast.
I think a subset of them and maybe
edited a little bit as a podcast,
and that has the benefit of
you not having to see my face
(chuckling)
which might be more pleasant
and you could drive.
So, I encourage you to
take a look at that.
I'll also make you know,
and I see the questions
starting to come in.
Before I start getting to them,
I'll make a couple of announcements
just in case y'all don't know about it.
Since we are into the
back to school period,
Khan Academy has a ton
of resources for you.
Hopefully you're aware of, you know,
we have pretty much every subject in grade
starting from pre-K through
the core of college,
we have Khan Academy Kids
that goes from a third grade
or a three year old to
six or seven year olds.
And that's reading, writing, math
and social emotional learning.
Everything I'm talking about is free,
not for profit, paid
for with those donations
which hopefully some of y'all are making.
We have math that obviously
goes well into elementary,
Middle High School and then college,
statistics, calculus
and even multi-variable.
We're about to launch a
multi-variable calculus
that has exercises in
the next couple of weeks.
We've also launched something called
Get Ready for Grade Level courses.
This is an issue that's always existed,
but it's frankly a bigger
issue now because of COVID.
That as kids come into
the new school year,
as you come into the new school year,
how do you know that you're ready
for whatever course you're getting into,
you can go to the Get
Ready for, let's say,
sixth grade course so they
Get Ready for algebra course,
take the course challenge.
If you do well on it, that
means you're pretty much ready.
If you don't do well on
it, then you can finish
and get mastery on that Get
Ready for Grade Level course,
it'll accelerate you
through the stuff you know,
by taking course
challenges and unit tests.
But at the other stuff,
you can make sure you
have a strong foundation,
which you can do in parallel
to the grade level course.
Or, you can do before
so that you have a
really strong foundation.
Another project I wanna make
sure that everyone knows about
before I jump into the questions.
There's a side project that I hope one day
might become part of Khan Academy
but today it is a side project.
It's called Schoolhouse.world.
And this is a place where you
as a student or your children,
or anyone you know, can get
free live group tutoring
from really well, from
accomplished and really good tutors
of frankly all ages and
if you wanna be a tutor,
you can also apply to be a tutor.
And right now, we have more
tutors and less students.
So, there's actually
several thousand slots
of where you can get free tutoring
especially we're starting
in high school math.
And then in the next few weeks,
we're probably going to
expand to K through 12 math,
the sciences, we're also
doing SAT in math now,
we'll probably do SAT tutoring in English
in the next few weeks as well.
So, of any age, if you're a
parent of a younger child,
say 13 or under, you'd be the person
who would have to go register
on Schoolhouse.world,
but encourage as many folks
as possible to go there,
you can kinda get on the waiting list,
but there's a lot of openings
for several thousands of folks right now
to start getting some free
group tutoring sessions live.
So with that, happy to
start taking some questions.
So, let's see from YouTube.
80 videos, there are
actually two questions.
"How can we get interested
in studying on our own?"
And 80 videos also says,
"what is the easiest way
to get interested in math?"
Well, I'll try to get
you interested right now.
You know, every subject
that you look at in school,
sometimes when you're
in school, you're like,
"Oh, this is being forced on me,
I have to do this for the test."
And when you think of it
that way, it loses sometimes
sometimes it might lose its joy.
But when you appreciate
that, as, you know,
as sentient beings in this universe,
one of the things that
makes humans humans is that
we're trying to understand
the universe we're living in,
and we're trying to understand
how do we interact with
society and the universe,
and have happy, productive lives.
And so, at the end of the day, knowledge
is really the underlying
thing that gives us clues
about the mystery we're in and
how we can interact with it.
And, the things that
you see in your textbook
or on Khan Academy or wherever else.
This is human knowledge
that has been accumulated
over thousands of years.
People have oftentimes
dedicated their entire lives
to one paragraph of your textbook
and you get to just see
the answer or the solution,
or the understanding right there.
And so, as you read your textbook
or as you learn in class,
or as you're on Khan
Academy, remind yourself
how lucky we are to have this knowledge.
And then also, never
be satisfied with just,
you know memorizing the
formula or figuring out
how to pattern match for the test.
Always think about how does this connect
to other things that I know?
How does this connect to my
understanding of the universe?
You know, when you, if
you're in chemistry class,
and you're learning
about atoms and electrons
and protons and neutrons you realize,
wow, these are mental constructs
that we as human beings
have formed to predict what
happens when these substances
interact with each other
in different conditions.
But what really is an atom?
Like, you know, if we can't
see it, if we can't touch it,
we can measure it in indirect ways.
You know, what does that really mean?
And, you know, what is real
if an atom is mostly open, free space.
If most of what we see around
ourselves is actually vacuum
and what I think is
solid is actually really
coulomb repulsive forces
between atoms that
don't want their electrons
to overlap with each other.
When you start to realize
like, wow, this is starting
to explain the philosophy of the universe
and, you know, you can
do that in any science.
You know, the humanities give us clues
about the human condition
and who are we as as beings,
and math, you know, there's
a special place for math
where that's the purest way
of understanding the universe.
If we ever come in contact with aliens,
that try to communicate with us,
math is going to be
our initial touch point
where we are able to
establish that the other party
is actually a sentient intelligent being,
is probably with math.
We'll probably try to, you
know, give them prime numbers
or something like that, or they
would give us prime numbers
to see whether we're actually
you know, intelligent
or some other type of
universal mathematical problem.
So, you know, I find math to
be the purest, most abstract...
everything else is kind
of clouded by our senses.
You know, even things like
physics and other sciences.
It's really all that we
can perceive and measure,
but math has a purity
to it that gets kind of,
at a much deeper state.
And, you know, there's definitely
some concepts out there in math
that I genuinely think
will blow your mind.
Wonder if y'all have all seen that video
where I talk about Euler's identity
where e to the i pi is
equal to negative one.
And that's one of those things,
that it just gives you chills
when you realize that e comes
from notions of continuously
compounding interest, the
derivative of a function
that's itself comes out of
some natural phenomenon,
exponential growth.
Pi, obviously, the ratio
of the circumference
is diameter of a circle,
i is a number that,
in some ways constructed by mathematicians
to have a, what could be the net squared,
defined as the square
root of negative one,
and the fact that there's
a very strong argument
that e to the i pi, these
things that come out
of completely different
domains equals negative one,
it's chilling, it's like
there's some hidden pattern
to the universe that we're
just getting glimpses of,
you know, some people have
called Euler's identity
proof of the existence of God, you know,
I'll leave it up to you to think about
whether you feel that or not.
But, I'm just trying to
make you appreciate that,
you know, the tools that
you're building in math class
are going to open up a
universe that will give you,
that will be awe inspiring.
And, they will give you
skills that will help you
be really productive
and useful and in life
and hopefully be able to support yourself
and support those of you who care about
and make a dent in the universe.
So anyway, long answer, you've
triggered me in a good way.
See other question.
From YouTube, Vincer Gaming,
"When did you really start love learning?"
You know, you can tell from
my answer, I just gave.
I love learning.
Like one of the reasons why I love my job
is a big part of my job is
I continue to make content
and I continue to learn new things,
so that I can really
intuitively understand them,
connect it to other things that I know
and hopefully communicate
it to y'all in ways
that are useful and other parts of my job
where we're growing an organization,
we're building software,
we're creating new content.
We're figuring out how
do we build awareness
for what we're doing, there's
also learning that I get to do
with really great people who teach me
and I get to learn from
experience as well.
I would say, you know,
early on, in my schooling,
it was kind of hit and miss.
Certain classes, I was
naturally excited about.
And I think I was lucky to
have some really great teachers
and then in other classes,
they didn't resonate as strongly
with me from an early age.
But then, by the time
I got to high school,
especially college, I
started to appreciate
how everything connected and
how empowering all of it was.
And then, I realized that, you
know, some of that learning
that I was doing for fun,
even outside of school
was really connected to the learning
that I was doing in school.
So, I think it's been a journey for me.
I think maybe when I was in my late teens
that I really unabashedly
become someone who,
you know, would very openly
say that I love learning,
'cause I really do think
it is the most human action we can do.
It's you know, we've been given
these 100 billion or so
neurons for a reason.
So, from YouTube, another
question from Vincer.
Actually, there's two
questions here from Vincer.
"How should you prepare for a test?"
And then from Nakheel Govenda,
"I hope you're well."
I'm doing great, thanks Nakheel.
"What are the best
studying methods techniques
to get a 90 and above
percentage in high school?"
So, for the best way to prepare for a test
is to be thinking about the
concepts well before the test.
And look, I'll say this as someone,
I still am a procrastinator sometimes,
but when I was young,
a teenager, in college,
I was a procrastinator.
So, I'm not gonna judge any of you
who are cramming for late night exams
or, you know, trying to
learn as much as you can
staying up all night, but I will tell you
as kind of Uncle Sal, that is not healthy.
And I've learned and if I
were to, if I had do overs,
if you just kind of, you
know, do a reasonable amount
every day and while you're doing it,
just don't pattern match
and do it robotically.
Really ponder it, think
about what you're working on.
By the time the test comes around,
you're gonna say like,
"Oh, this is intuitive."
Because you're ti... your
brain will have had a chance
to really marinate in the knowledge.
And, you know, the one
thing I will tell you
and this is a skill that I
learned actually in college.
You know, what, I had
a degree in, I was...
I majored in electro-engineering,
computer science
and another in math.
And, in some of those
theoretical math classes,
you know, you look at the
problems that you're given,
let's say a topology
class, and you're like,
"Okay, I understand the problem,
but I have no idea how to
approach this problem."
And what I found is, if you
give your brain the problem,
you think about it for a few minutes
and then you kind of delegate the problem
to your subconscious and
maybe even sleep on it,
literally sleep on it, that the next day,
all of a sudden your subconscious,
like passes you a memo
like, hey, this is the answer.
And you're like, oh, okay, yes, I know,
I can now do that topological proof.
And, so I learned in undergraduate,
you know, essentially
having challenges like this
that like, we have an
incredible, you know,
our consciousness, the part
that we strongly associate with
is just a small part of the
horsepower that you have.
And I truly believe everyone has.
I mean, these hundreds
of billions of neurons
that we have working for us.
And so, you know, learn
to trust and delegate.
So, the way that you do that
is you prime your brain,
you take the knowledge in, you read it,
you try to get... maybe watch a video
to try to get some practice,
maybe some of it sticks.
Maybe some of it sticks
enough to do the problem,
but you still don't have
a strong intuition yet.
Let it marinate.
If you don't know how to do
the problem, let it marinate.
You'd be surprised 24 hours later,
all of a sudden you know how to do it.
Now, what I just described
is not a great technique for cramming
because it takes a little
bit of a leap of faith
and sometimes it might not
hit for 24 hours or 48 hours.
I'd be surprised if it actually
takes longer than that.
But, it's all about
creating a habit of learning
in whatever subject but
regardless of whatever timeframe
you're doing it, whether
you're doing it in a healthy,
you know, regular way or
whether you're cramming
before a test, always
try to draw connections,
always try to, just don't
assume that A leads to C,
say why does A lead to C?
Is it 'cause it leads to B first?
But then why does it lead to B?
Talk to people about it,
have conversations about it,
and that conversing about it,
also another way to draw connections.
You know, I will say that, you know,
I've always been skeptical
of actually group studying
that, you know, sometimes
studying is a solitary activity.
And I actually think, you
know, sometimes group study
is kind of not as productive
as you would like.
So, I would always say, your
first goal should be you
and the material digging deep in it.
And then, once you, but if
you have some time and space,
which ideal you have, then it's great
to be able to talk about it with friends,
once you've both had a chance
to kind of struggle around with it.
And then, I think having
conversation can be really good.
The other thing I would say,
is just get in the right frame of mind.
I think for a lot of
folks, just the stress
and the anxiety associated with tests
become the thing that
makes it hard for them
to take the test or do well on the test.
And so, I highly recommend meditating.
We've actually made
meditations on Khan Academy,
you know, recognize that
your life is so much more
than a performance on any one test that,
that, you know, 100 years from
now, no one's going to care
how you performed on one test or another.
So, you know, just keep
that in mind that you know,
a test, it's important to be prepared,
do your best, but be in the
Zen state as you take it.
Don't be all caught up with
like, what's gonna happen
if I do badly on the
test or I have to do well
if I you know, I want this to happen.
That's going to be counterproductive.
Let's see.
There's from Facebook, Lisa Willtrout,
"What platform do you recommend
to learn science terms
for long-term memory?
Is there an existing flashcard site?"
So, you know, for flashcard
type stuff, there is Quizlet.
I recommend it.
I'm good friends with
the founder of Quizlet.
And, I'm sure there's people
who've already created
flashcards on Quizlet
for whatever you need to learn
and you can also create
your own flashcards
and they have some really neat modalities
where you can, you know,
have kind of flashcards
but there's other ways to make sure
that you've essentially
memorized the knowledge.
I would say Khan Academy is a great place
for practicing the skills
and the concepts of science
and a little bit of
the not, the knowledge,
I guess you could call it
memorization if you like.
So, if you go to Khan Academy
for biology or chemistry or physics,
chemistry and physics don't
have a lot of memorization,
I would argue even some of the formulas,
once you understand the
intuition behind them,
you don't need to memorize
them and you can see it
and you can even derive some
from some of the others.
Biology has a little bit of memorization,
but once again, it's more conceptual.
You know, in some classes,
you might have to memorize the
phases of mitosis or meiosis
or, you know, things like that.
But, I think Khan Academy
really has your back
and you know, fingers crossed,
I'm hoping that in the next few months,
we have the resources to actually
really flash out a middle
school and early high school
science on Khan Academy.
We actually have high
school science already,
but really take that to the next level.
So, you know, stay tuned.
We already have a lot of
science on Khan Academy,
both high school and AP level,
you know, chemistry, biology, physics,
and we're building out
more of the high school.
Hope to have middle school soon.
And obviously, we have
college level 'cause the AP
and the college level are
essentially the same thing.
We also have things like econ.
So, yeah, check out Khan Academy,
but Quizlet is also a great place
to make sure you memorize your facts.
So, from YouTube, Suzanna Garcia Domingues
and Suzanna, I feel like I know you
because you are a consistent,
strong question asker on these,
I don't even look at the
question when I have a guest on
and I see it's from Suzanna and I'm like,
that's gonna be a good question.
I'm just gonna read it before
I even know what she's asking.
So Sal asks, so Suzanna asks,
"Hi, Sal, you're such a happy person.
Would you have any pet peeves?"
Well, I'm happy that you
think I'm a happy person.
I look, I do think for the
most part, I am a happy person.
But, I have my share of you
know, every now and then,
I've talked about this, you know, I get,
I've been anxious on planes.
I've learned to deal with it.
Actually, that's what
brought me to meditation,
which has actually made
me a much happier person.
'Cause it is easy,
especially when you feel like
you're working on
something really important.
And I feel like Khan Academy,
we gotta get this right.
There's millions of folks depending on us.
And so, sometimes at
work if you know people
are disagreeing with something
or something didn't happen
the way that you wanted,
you know, you get,
you might get a little
triggered or you go home
and you lose sleep, you're like wake up,
you're like, oh, how come
this can't happen faster?
Why did that person say that?
Or, and, you know, I've
learned through meditation
to not even let that happen.
That when, you know, it's
important to engage on a problem
and do what you can but then
you need to compartmentalize
that a little bit and
not let it affect you
and not let you mull on it.
And until a lot of times, I, you know,
to the previous question, I
delegated to my subconscious
and let my, I say, "subconscious,
you worry about it.
I gotta sleep."
And usually when I wake
up the next morning
or the, you know, a week later, you know,
the thing that I thought was this problem
that could have kept me up.
There's usually a solution,
it usually resolves itself
or, come up with the
solution and you realize,
yeah, that was a silly
thing to stress over.
So once you go through enough
cycles like that in life,
there's many things that
in high school, college,
you know, I stressed over?
Well, I, you know, I'm sure a lot of kids
are stressed about college admissions now,
you know, we all had
our childhood crushes.
Does that person even see me?
You know, do I have the
guts to walk up to them
and talk to them?
You know, will I pick the right major?
How do I make friends?
You know, fear of missing out.
Can I pick the right career?
How am I going to pay off my debt?
You know, these are all
stresses and anxieties.
And did someone say that about me,
but that's not who I am.
I'm really a nicer person than that.
And, you know, over time, you just realize
that these things that stress you out,
a week later, six months later
really aren't that important.
And so, when someone new
and comes up, you're like,
you know what, six months from now,
if something needs fixing, I'll fix it.
If there's some action I
can take that's productive,
I'll take it.
But, don't let it bother you.
And meditation really helps there,
because meditation, you
know, our minds are normally
just all over the place.
You're like, you know, I wonder if a horse
and a zebra can breed.
Oh, I gotta pay my taxes.
Am I a good father?
That's like five seconds of your brain
if you just let it, you
know, can I outrun a bear?
You can't.
You know, but even those
big, you know, chubby bears,
no, you can't outrun them, you know.
So, your brain is like a circus,
it's all sorts of stuff is
going on from moment to moment.
And meditation is really
getting it back to a place
where you're just like this
candle and without wind,
you know, you're just still
and you're not thinking.
And it's when you're
in that frame of mind,
you know, there's nothing, you know,
this can apply to any religion.
You know, in every religion
there's been mystics
who have gotten well-steeped in meditation
and they've been able to still their mind
and when you still your mind,
you start appreciating how silly
some of the things that you
were taking seriously are
and you start appreciating that you know,
at the end of the day, all you really are,
you know, that you can
really claim you are
is a consciousness, and
even you know these notions
of your identity and your name
and your physical persona,
these are just part of material reality.
These are, and some of these
things are constructed,
you know, your persona,
your place in society,
your connections and that
liberates you a little bit.
And I see the other reason
I'm happy is I think
I've just been very lucky in life.
You know, I get to do what I love.
You know, I have a wonderful
wife, wonderful kids,
I get to, you know, work
with wonderful people.
And I think there's no
there's nothing like that,
you know, I guess makes
you click your heels
on the way to work which
is now in my house.
Alright, so Facebook,
Mohammed Ibrahims says,
"Sal, do you play video games?
Kind of.
So, I don't wanna, this might
create an unpleasant image
for many of y'all, but I'm
a big fan of Just Dance.
I find it to be an
incredibly good workout.
And, you know, it's kind
of a type of video game
that you can play and not feel guilty
that you played it because
it's a good workout.
You can play it with the
kids, whole family can play.
It's very social.
So, I'm a fan of that.
You know, growing up, I
didn't, I was the kid,
you know, we couldn't afford
a video game system, really.
So, I was the kid that would
go to my friend's house
and kind of watch them play Nintendo.
Every now and then they
would hand the joystick to me
and I was like, no, I'm just
used to watching, you know.
So, I didn't play a
lot growing up, I mean,
and to some degree,
I'm careful about them.
Because I, you know, I
think I would naturally
be sucked into them if I let
myself get sucked into them.
And, you know, I definitely
need to be careful
that I don't get sucked
into things like that,
especially now, I mean, now
I wouldn't get sucked in
'cause I have, I'm an adult.
I have stuff to do and
I have children to raise
and, you know, a wife
and family, you know,
but, you know, I think there's a danger
of getting sucked into them.
So, you know, with my kids,
you know, they're really,
they're 11, nine and five.
They're really into Minecraft right now.
We limit them to just Sunday mornings,
they can do Minecraft.
So, you know, and Minecraft in
the whole spectrum of games,
is actually quite good.
It's creative and et cetera.
But, it can also become super immersive
and the kids kind of have trouble
getting themselves out of that world.
So, yeah, I think in moderation
video games can be great and
I highly recommend Just Dance.
If you're ever on that, whatever
they have the global dance floor,
I think my username is Khan something,
so you might see me some time
on the global dance floor
on dance, on Just Dance.
(chuckling)
From Facebook, Yulia
Coraleyva,
"Do you play chess? Do you like Chess?
I would like to learn to play.
The reason I ask you about it
is just because you're a great teacher."
Well, thank you.
"So I think you'll be able to
teach this game on your site."
So, I do play chess.
I would consider myself
a very good amateur.
I played chess, you know, I
first played when I was five.
My uncles taught me to play.
I never kind of played competitively.
I would say, you know,
that I've had a few
highlights in my chess life.
There was a event at
one of our funders house
where Magnus Carlsen showed
up and played a demo game
against four people
and he was blindfolded.
And I was one of the four people.
And, there was a moment and he was playing
three other people and
and he was blindfolded.
So, I'm not claiming
that I'm anywhere close.
But there was a moment
where I guess his visual
'cause he was clearly
memorizing four boards at once.
He had, he made a mistake
and I had the advantage.
I had a rookie advantage
on Magnus Carlsen.
And that actually made me nervous.
I was like, I cannot mess
this up at this point.
And then like, he beat
the other three players
pretty quickly and then I
just felt his chess brainpower
completely focused on
me, like crushing me,
and I just, I just, I choked.
But, he came up, you know,
took the blindfold off,
and he kind of came up and he
was kind of like, "Good game.
You know, I was nervous for a moment."
That's the peak of by my chess career.
And, I have to say my son,
my oldest son named Ron,
he's really into chess and
he has made me a lot better.
We play couple of times a week
and I have to give him credit.
He has a really great
growth mindset about it.
About a year ago, I would
win about 70% of the game
and he's quite good as you can imagine
for an 11 year old considering, you know,
I had an advantage momentarily
against Magnus Carlsen
while he was playing blindfolded
and four other people.
But now, he wins about 60% of
the games and if I beat him,
he's like, "Okay, give me a few hours."
And then he goes, you asked about a site,
he goes to the site called Chess Kids,
which I think is great.
You know, it's like a $4
a month type membership.
Obviously, I'm a big fan of
free world class learning,
but I think you know, that's a
good deal for learning chess,
'cause it has really good
exercises and he's learned a lot
and I'm not on the site, but
he's making me a lot better.
And sometimes he explains
the new techniques
that he learns on chess.
But, I really like that whenever he loses,
he doesn't like throw a tantrum.
He's like, "give me a few hours."
Then he goes on Chess Kids
and he works his skills.
And then he's like, "Dad, you wanna play?"
When he has that look,
"Dad, you wanna play?"
I know I'm about to be crushed.
And, I'm gonna have to up
level myself a little bit.
No, 'cause I think it's a wonderful game.
Very, and you learn
frankly a lot about life.
You learn a lot about, you know, patience.
It's a wonderful game.
So, YouTube, Adrian Avila,
"What was your band's
name in high school?"
I mean, I'm ashamed to say
'cause I'm really not a negative person.
And, you know, but in high school,
our band's name was Malignancy.
It was a heavy metal band.
We were enamored with names that sounded,
I don't know,
horrifying in some way
or yeah, but that was it.
We actually changed the name,
or we were nameless for a while
'cause there was some
other band named that.
It was, we, you know, I was on one side
this very curious, academic
kid but there was a side,
I was a little bit angsty and angry.
And so, I was drawn at that age to fairly
extreme heavy metal and
I was the lead singer.
I guess you could say, lead
screamer, lead growler.
But, you know, there was a weekend
where I had to pick between
going to National Academic Games
and performing with our band,
which was our first gig.
I think we were going to open
for a band called Paralysis
and I picked National
Academic Games and so,
who knows the path not taken.
But now, you know, I still
really enjoy playing guitar
and singing and but I
definitely do much more
of a kind of a folk singer,
songwriter, classic rock.
You know, Bob Dylan, Brandi
Carlile type of music,
so most of my angst has
been exorcised from me.
So, Mohammed says, I use your
math videos for meditation.
Well, you know, math can
be a form of meditation.
You know, the kind of
classic form of meditation
is kind of sit still, eyes closed
and focus on your
breathing and become still.
But, you know, anytime you're
doing something mindfully,
and your brain isn't all over the place,
that's a form of meditation.
So, if you're in a math problem
and your brain is kind
of still in that space,
that sometimes happens in sports,
it can, you know, happen when
you're listening to music,
creating something, that's
a form of meditation.
So, that's the first I've heard of that
but I'm happy that someone can find
a Khan Academy video meditative.
So, Sanu and Abraham says,
"How can we practice meditation
or teach with a
hyperactive four year old?"
I don't know.
I mean, I've tried to convince
my kids to meditate with me
and they do, you know, my older
kids do to certain degree.
The school they go to, the Khan Lab School
which I helped start, they
have, they do some meditation,
which I think is really great.
But, for younger kids, it's just really,
honestly a four or five
year old, even 30 seconds.
If they can sit silently
for 30 seconds, it's a win.
And if you build that habit,
then they'll become a little,
honestly 10 seconds, start
with 10 seconds and you know,
give them like an M&M at the end of it.
But it starts to build a
muscle where you start to,
you know, you'd be surprised
how many adults have trouble
just sitting quietly, eyes
closed with themselves,
with their own mind.
To some degree, they wanna get distracted,
so they don't have to deal with everything
their brain is kind of throwing at them.
So, for me, you know, I found in the early
when I was starting to meditate,
you know, even two, three
minutes your brain is saying,
oh, somewhat, you know,
there's a lot more outside,
you can't meditate.
You're hungry, you know, your back hurts.
You know, do I itch my nose or not?
Will that break the meditation?
But then, you just keep it,
you keep doing it as a habit.
And now, I do 30 minutes
at least once a day
and you know, I don't claim
to be some type of, you know,
person whose mind is always still
and I've somehow reached Nirvana.
But there are moments where
I do feel that stillness
and there is, it almost feels euphoric.
And time, you know,
when my meditation timer
on my phone rings, a little chime,
I feel like the tie, I was
like, oh, wow, you know,
I was in this inward journey.
So, it's a muscle that
you can build over time.
But you know, my five year old, you know,
we're not like this family
that is like, you know,
we're a bunch of monks and
we meditate all the time.
I'm trying, I'm trying
'cause I think honestly,
you know, there's these
stereotypical things
you wanna instill with your kids,
you wanna make sure they
have a lot of you know,
academic capabilities so that
they get you know, a good job.
You wanna make sure they're good people,
that they're ethical, that
they have a good work ethic,
but I think the resilience of meditation
that you get, you know,
that's the ultimate thing
because life's gonna throw
curve balls at everyone
and some folks we're gonna get
bigger curve balls than others.
But if folks can always
be grounded, be present,
have gratitude for what
they have and be mindful.
You know, they're gonna get through it.
And so, yeah, I would say keep trying,
keep trying, eventually it'll work.
Someone's asking me to sing.
I don't, there's no time for that.
So, maybe we have time
for one more question.
I'm been told by the team.
Maybe I'll, you know, I still
have live on social media
sing, that's, I'll work my way up to it.
I don't have the guitar
here. It's in the garage.
So, let's see.
I'll do one.
So, one question Ivana Garibaldi says,
"Jumping on a bit late.
Can you talk more about
Schoolhouse.world a little bit?
I heard you're starting
with high school math,
what other subjects would
you be looking to roll out?
Timing, can high school
students taking advanced classes
volunteer as tutors?"
So, Ivana, Schoolhouse.world
is exactly that.
It's a place where students
who need help in a subject
can sign up for free live
group tutoring sessions.
And, if you feel and there
are high school students
that are also the volunteer
tutors and actually some of them
are some of the really
good tutors out there.
So, you can also volunteer
and you can do both.
Right now as I mentioned, it's
starting in high school math.
But if you're at all interested in it,
I would go and register and
we're gonna notify people
over time because we're,
you know, there's no reason
why we can't expand to other subjects
and other grade levels.
So, we're gonna be doing that
probably over the next month or so.
We're gonna be adding a bunch
of more grade levels on,
so whether you wanna be a tutor
in say English on the SAT,
or a tutor young kids learning math
or you wanna be the
recipient of the tutoring,
I encourage folks to go to
Schoolhouse.world, sign up.
As I mentioned, we actually
are looking for more students.
We can easily handle
several thousand more students right now.
And obviously if anyone's
interested in tutoring,
that's great too, because we
can handle even more students.
And, you know, the dream
here is and this is...
COVID was the catalyst
to make this happen.
But, the dream here is that in short order
we have tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of folks
who are able to help each other,
which obviously has the
benefit where you can learn
at your own time and pace on Khan Academy,
but you can get real live help.
But, in this time of social distancing,
hopefully they can connect people,
they can build empathy for other folks.
You know, when you become a tutor,
you learn the material that much better.
And, you're helping folks
and you're building empathy
and communication skills.
So, encourage folks to
check out Schoolhouse.world
and all the other stuff
we're doing at Khan Academy.
Schoolhouse.world just remember,
it's not officially a
Khan Academy project.
It's a Sal project.
Who knows, maybe they might converge
at some point in the future.
So anyway, time always goes
by fast when we're having fun.
Maybe I'll have the guitar
next to me next time.
But, it was really really good questions
and thanks everyone for asking them.
I think we're not doing this tomorrow,
but I will see you next week
at the Homeroom livestream.